hello everyone i'm alan and welcome to
my channel where today we are doing an
unboxing of the resident evil village
collectors edition a lot of resident
evil content
on my channel right now but i'm a huge
fan of the series i'm enjoying village
a whole lot and uh capcom
is cable what kind enough to send me the
collector's edition so we're going to
open it up
let's do it the first thing is the
outside is just a kind of a
sleeve that tells you everything that's
inside it so we have a reversible cloth
map i love
a cloth map resident evil village deluxe
edition a steel book
the deluxe edition dlc pack voucher a
12-inch chris redfield figure which is
what i'm most excited about premium
packaging a collector's art book
and the deluxe edition also includes a
summer edge handgun mr everywhere weapon
charm visual filter safer music save
point skin digital art book
and higher difficulty unlock um so this
part obviously looks like a kind of uh
chest so we're just gonna slide this out
i think yep
okay here is the chest in all of its
design this is actually really neat i
love a
nicely designed box very cool
okay some sticky tape i'm gonna have to
take care of one here one cut
two cuts okay opening her up
okay at the very top of the box all we
have
the steelbook and the game itself for
playstation 4.
the game obviously can confirm
is video game trying to get my camera to
focus on the game this is going to be a
steel book right here this is actually
really nice
let me bring you in close up gotta get
those steel book details
it's very nice it's like a kind of like
an old book
obviously there's gonna be nothing in
here
but uh yeah it's a very nice very nice
still case okay then we lift
this part up cardboard
this is going to be our cloth map i just
way prefer them to the paper ones or the
plasticy ones
but i'm gonna try not to look at it too
hard as i haven't finished the game yet
let me see it
and then on the back we've got village
a traveler's record this says oh that's
more cardboard okay
all right cardboard this says village
resident evil a traveler's
record this is a book this art book
contains designs and information that
can be seen throughout resident evil
village we recommend playing through the
game first to avoid any spoilers so i
haven't played a fair amount
but uh ah yeah i've played more than is
currently uploaded on the channel so i
am
ahead of that but i haven't finished it
yet so
this is uh that opening bit that looked
a lot like coraline or a lot like harry
potter a lot of people were saying
very pretty this is very cool but i will
follow its advice and not read too far
through
looks like there are 63 pages in total
very impressive nice hardcover uh book
design big fan of that okay
this is the piece de la resistance um
this is gonna be
our big boy chris redfield right here
okay
that out of the way here it is i'm gonna
be honest i'm sure everyone is glad it's
chris rather than you did wishes
he's not a fan favorite turns out out of
here
okay oh that's a big base that's a big
base you've got me
all right camera down for you got little
bits to cut because of course we do
always pop chris out
oh i'm surprised this is all one piece
there are more separate parts that's
interesting
i'll show you guys before i make any
decisions tall boy
it's pretty well textured i'll say that
so you can see if we turn it around here
it's all textured on the back and i do
like the um
the wrinkling on his uh on his shirt too
that's nice i think his face
actually looks pretty good i feel like
um a lot of these quality of statues
have pretty bad faces
i think his facial hair is pretty bad
and actually weirdly obviously
printed i can see the uh
pixels which is a strange thing to have
on the face of a figure so
yeah his beard is not great pretty
blotchy and like i just said you can
literally see the pixels on it which is
really strange but otherwise
his eyes look pretty good i like the
expression it's a little bit ominous i
think his hair looks alright
yeah it's not a great figure but we'll
take it i'm happy to have it oh and it
stands up by itself oh my god
that's always my favorite thing in the
world we have
a gun in the front here that we're just
gonna put in his hand
slotted in there quite nicely as someone
who just recently uh put together
uh an action figure which obviously this
is just a figure
um it definitely just fits in there
perfectly it's
there's no stretching of thumbs or
anything it goes exactly where it's
supposed to
more sticky tape damn it and here is the
base
it's really light really really really
light i love this nameplate on the front
i think that that's really nice
obviously just says chris redfields
and then he's gonna stand on it like
this
very nice oh there he is
good stuff i
generally don't like a huge base like i
said i really like the name plate on
this but because i don't have a lot of
space
and he stands up by himself i'm actually
just gonna store this base and i'm gonna
keep him on my shelf
without one um that is a huge plus to me
as much as i
this base is definitely just plastic but
it is nice so for me
he's just gonna stand up like so and
we're going to store this somewhere else
for safekeeping but that is it for the
resident evil 7 collector's edition
unboxing
um because that was pretty short i don't
know if you can see it over my shoulder
here i do actually have another thing
that i'm just going to throw into this
unboxing
because why not so for anyone who
doesn't know
uh doom one 1993 that is not 2016
is one of my favorite games ever made i
absolutely adore it i think it's
fantastic doom 1993 which is the year i
was born
is where it's at this is a classic doom
helmet
collector's bundle that features this
wearable
doom helmet it says full size wearable
replica from the classic doom detail
battle damage painting inner adjustable
head straps it also comes with a
lithograph poster a floppy disk
pin and it says dimensions are 13 by 14
by 11.4 the limited edition floppy disk
pin
is metal and enamel classic 3.5 inch
disc shape features classic doom logo
and um the lithograph print is 12x17 so
let's open it up so this is the the pin
i do get a lot of pins with collectors
editions and i know some people don't
like them because they don't have
anywhere to put them
um i just put them on basically
double-sided fridge magnets so i just
put them on top of my fridge magnets
which i really like
this is our lithograph this is gonna be
tough to unravel it does feel like it's
really nice quality
this is neat this is very neat
i can't show it to you much better than
that i do bad unboxings everyone you
should know that by now
this is cool though and then this is
going to be the helmet itself
this is so light it's wild
it basically weighs nothing oh my god
it's very big
oh my okay hello
hello there
mm-hmm yeah
i think i like it let me try it on
it's huge um okay so there's a strap in
here that i need to adjust that was just
dangling over my face there pull this
out
push that up oh super easy to adjust
okay and now it should like
actually sit to show you the inside
there's a padded top
and i basically just made this a bunch
longer
so now
oh my god it is properly wearable
it's actually pretty comfortable for the
record you can't see out of it it's
super blurry would not recommend
using it um to fight demons but uh i
think these cracks are a little bit
silly the mold for those is just
obviously very plasticky
but the wearing and the weathering i
think looks very nice this sort of
rust just like messy scratches across it
again i think this stuff looks a bit
silly but
the rest of it awesome and that is it
for me today everyone just two things i
was excited to unbox
got my two new friends here that i'm
gonna have to find room for
somewhere and that is it for me today i
will see you guys next time